it's a fundamental breach of trust and
of course it violates
the whole concept of trust and
essentially britain had signed up to
this agreement
and had entered into it with united over
the european union
and has now unilaterally caused a breach
of this
i think in addition to that um it also
is very much anti-business and
anti-industry
in northern ireland because i would have
spoken to industry representatives
some weeks ago and they're very very
concerned about the dual regulatory
idea
particularly in terms of traceability of
goods and it would have a real impact on
the food industry in particular and i
don't think it's well thought out or
well thought through
and certainly doesn't match the
realities on the ground in terms of
the experiences of those involved in
various industries so for example those
involved in manufacturing
were doing particularly well under the
protocol and they're now very concerned
not just by the uncertainty that has
been created
but also the
fact that this represents an undermining
of conditions
which were very conducive to a good
manufacturing
performance and northern was doing very
well
under the protocol and the bottom line
following my consultations with those
involved in industry and business um was
that the only way to resolve this is
through substantive negotiations
between the uh british government
and and the european union and we
already know that negotiations of that
kind did result for example in the
resolution of the medicines issue
uh so and there was progress made in
terms of marijuana's package last
october in terms of sps
um and in terms of customs so clearly
the platform was always there to resolve
this through negotiation but there's
been an absence of will on behalf of the
british government to really resolve
this through negotiation and it's time
now
for those substantive negotiations to
commence an earnest